photographer Jonathan Albury travels the
world to document the stark realities of
war he has covered conflicts in places
from Afghanistan and Ethiopia to Ukraine
and Egypt but on a trip to Syria in
April of 2013 al Peru was kidnapped
while moving toward the frontlines his
new book details that 81 day ordeal the
shattered lens a war photographers true
story of captivity and survival in Syria
is published by atria an imprint of
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS
Jonathan Alpert joins us now good
morning Jonathan morning take us back to
that moment when you were captain so
this was my third trip into Syria and
this time I decided to go through
Lebanon in order to cover the fighting
near Damascus which was very heavy at
the time and at the time the rebels were
still at the upper hands and there was
an anklet which you get smuggled into
and from there I cover the basically the
battle between mostly Hezbollah infantry
and syrian air force against various
rebel forces and after ten days the kids
side to kidnap me instead of letting me
go
do you remember what went through your
mind in that moment when you were
kidnapped yeah it's very strange I think
like most traumatic experiences
everything goes very slowly excuse me
and then you you think it's not really
happening and it's not real there's a
mistake and everything will get resolved
so usually there's that moment when you
you think that you're actually dreaming
what you're going through you were
blindfolded handcuffed and I know beaten
during your captivity 81 days yeah for
81 days the first month is love
torturing going on mock executions
interrogations and they play a game with
you where one day they're very nice and
the other day they're very difficult
with you I think it's meant partially to
break your will and to keep you on your
toes so you don't really know what to do
if you want to escape or try anything
against them so they really break you up
like that who were the captors so you
have as you know many rebel factions in
Syria it's a very complicated affair but
at the time I was mostly local militias
or fighting the regime but because they
were having such difficult problems with
the Hezbollah in French
they brought in a lot of Al nusra front
people were much more experienced and
discipline at fighting so they did it do
you think yeah I mean it's all connected
and yeah definitely you you talk in the
book about gaining the trust of your
captors how did you do that it's so nice
it's a question of survival you have to
pick out who you can trust and who you
don't trust usually I would go after the
younger soldiers who were more
interested in the fight I was from the
western world they were more curious
about me so they were nicer to me the
torturing and beatings were done mostly
by the older or the officer group so I
spent a lot of time manipulating these
young guys to make sure I would get the
Oh favors like making sure my handcuffs
were not as tight or maybe a lot to go
to the bathroom one extra time during
the day just very little things that
make your life easier so how did you
escape well there was a ransom which is
often the case when it comes to
kidnapping that was given out to by men
which I can't give the name of of course
but he he was part of a blacklist that
was written down by the European Union
and the United States of powerful Syrian
men like himself who are parliamentary
and close to the regime but also do
businesses around the world and when
you're on that list you can't travel
they freeze your assets and he wanted
that to be gone obviously so by paying
for me and releasing me he was hoping to
give to get a favor from the United
States or friends and be freed from it
which happened briefly and then he was
put back right on that list I would
would you ever go back to Syria of
course I always tempted to go back to
these different war zones just for
personal reasons after the war when it
ends which will most likely happen
fairly soon I would definitely like to
go back and see the places where I was
kid I was captured yeah well Jonathan
Albury thank you so much for joining us
and cue we appreciate it we're glad
you're back home safe